santé I can definitely tell you're not a
cheap guide the most thing sit on my lap
what do you want for Christmas this
beard sticks on you no yeah
I'm Jill Julie celebrate Hanukkah
I like lighting the candles like um
those people did in the desert I like to
spin the dreidel I like potatoes like a
lot honey because about being with your
family but I'm a little dirty I like the
presents myself Santa doesn't come to my
house because I'm Jewish and also I
don't believe in Santa Claus on
Christmas Eve he goes into her house and
gives you present through the Germany in
Santa has reindeers he has like a nest
of nice and naughty and the thing I
don't believe is he loves forever now
that's what kind of puts me on the fence
there I'm them from that Santa before do
you want to meet him right now yeah
there's the Claus oh oh my goodness Smee
Santa Claus I'm so glad to see you
Osborne rule can I sit there
here let me help you out do you hang out
with hairy Hanukkah I love back
scratchers by the way so the joyful game
is you spin the dreidel with your friend
probably you need two people but then I
turned smaller when I go down into
chimneys and then pop back out into
normal size no I'm sure it did probably
land on something like I'm a Hebrew
leather and whatever it says you do
doctor go switch boop an area again it's
it's some strange stories for sure no
matter about presents you know you need
to be you and live life if it means no
presence of being with your family
sometimes gotta live with it you know
and I feel exactly the same way
I wanted oh well thank you sweetie I
appreciate that
you wanna take a little bite off the
other room yeah sure I met Shanna same
time to shine
Thank You Sadie I love you too